let's do some my laughs okay the bad
news is that was the landlord or evicted
the good news is we got nothing left a
little crank out the music your
ex-girlfriend is dating AC Slater big
fan Oh huge fan now none of the host
thing [ __ ] but you know I'm still
living like one college wait are you
breaking up with us I think I am
breaking up with you guys don't you [ __ ]
that is not good it's over
you need to try new things you need to
meet new people holy [ __ ] that's haven't
meant to do that
that was for you buddy you see some
nipple I was really looking at her
nipples and are we selling nipple what's
going on in my kitchen it just kind of
happened ready yeah [ __ ] you about to
enter the [ __ ] jungle oh no don't
worry this is how I we heard growling
and crying last night cuz I thought you
were just watching Animal Planet stoned
again can you see the guys
mm-hm can you just do something like it
like I just made a joke like laughs
you're trying to make him jealous
please do this for me right
what'd he say where that is stated okay
I cannot be in the middle anymore
[Music]
kind of package for you Oh says it's
from you oh no no no wait no sorry yep
for me or no it's uh for me or I mean it
could be read if you want it you don't
want it no I don't want it of course you
don't want it put those dick somewhere
I'll take care of it I I have a place
for them hi thirsty check it out
that my friend is bar circle bar let's
be stupid people man guys decided that
we were gonna do a pub crawl
cuz it's our anniversary do you even
know an our anniversary is not today is
it what did you get me
you guys haven't changed one bit
thank you not a compliment have any of
us changed at all since we've met each
other yes how he's better now
significantly fatter yeah I did it on
purpose
we'll still living like we're in college
wait are you breaking up with us I think
I am breaking up with you guys you're
drunk
you don't want to say something you're
not gonna be able to take that it's over
you're over it's over you need to try
new things you need to meet new people
hey hey did you go shopping you are good
look at my man
guess I never really appreciated that
when we were together can you see the
guys mm-hmm just do something like it
like I just made a joke back laugh to
try to make him jealous please do this
for me all right
what do you say well let me say okay I
cannot be in the middle anymore
[Music]
okay the strippers are here you batch
lotsa 500 I put it oh you girls are
linked
Yami's ooh
you